hello everyone and welcome to the
aimchess u.s rapid knockouts it's the
quarterfinals and it's magnus cross and
versus young [ __ ] of duda after
achieving that brilliant win against
jordan van forest um duda now faces
magnus again with the black pieces so
let's see if he can create something as
as interesting
against the world champion and it's it's
a really interesting game a lot of games
from this round are interesting and i
will try to cover
a few more uh wesley versus alireza is
the one that i'm showing next so that
one will be uploaded very shortly after
this one so magnus with the white pieces
opens with knight to f3 he goes for the
ready opening with d5
g3 g6 and bishop to g2 we have bishop to
g7 and here we have castle's king side
so this is nothing new king's indian
attack the double fianchetto variation
knight to f6 and now c4 challenging
blacks d-pawn
we have c6 the defending the pawn and
now b3 preparing to develop the uh dark
square bishop by fianchettoing it and
here knight to e4 now opening up an
attack here towards the white rook but
white just plays d4 so blocking the
attack we have castles by black and now
bishop to b2
we have bishop to f5 by duda a very nice
developing square for the bishop and now
e3 by magnus we have a5 and now comes
knight to c3 so just normal developing
moves nothing out of the ordinary here
knight to d7 and now queen to e2
connecting the rooks uh we have knight
captures and c3 bishop captures and
bishop to e4 now asking white what do
you want to do and here uh white could
continue in a
couple of different ways he could for
example start bringing the rooks into
the game but uh there's the very
interesting pawn captures on d5 because
now uh if white captures if black
captures with the bishop then we play e4
and we get this massive center so of
course black will not allow this black
played c captures on d4 and now we have
queen to b5 that was the idea of the
capture on the five to three of the
queen uh the b5 square for the queen and
now we're attacking the b7 pawn so do
the defensive he wants to develop his
queen uh rook f the c1 now aligning the
rook with the queen on the c file and
the queen to c6 now offering a queen
trade and magnus happily trades here
captures captures because there's now
the backwards c6 pawn that to do that
we'll have to worry about uh and here
there are uh there is a game where
bishop to h3 was played in this position
going after this knight but the move
that magnus plays knight to e1 is a new
move so now it is not until move 17 that
we have a completely new game and this
is basically where our game starts uh
and here uh we have uh not not capture
so dude i'm not interested in uh sort of
improving the the position of white's
king he just plays g5 and it makes sense
uh stops f4
or or h4 at any point and you will have
a very nice pawn here on g5 well
probably for the for for a very long
time so here magnus captures we have
bishop capture spawn captures and now
rook the c2 getting ready to double up
rooks and the c file uh there is not
much you can do about the the spawn here
so
uh
it makes no sense to attack it right
away we have rook f the b8 uh and now
comes rook eight to c1 now preparing to
move the bishop and capture the c6 pawn
and here duda wants to create some
counter chances with a4 uh we have b4 by
magnus and now comes a3 and we're gonna
talk about this a3 move a little bit
because
you could defend the pawn for example if
uh you play some like rook to a6 and
magnus moves the bishop you could play
the other rook to b6 and you are
defending this pawn but it's a very
passive position for black and maybe not
the greatest idea to try and play
something like this against magnus so
duda goes with the active idea that he
plays a3
and now bishop to d2 going after the c6
pawn we have e6 by duda
and now rook captures on c6 and now duda
will shift all of his pieces to to
attack the
the b4 pawn so bishop to f8 going after
the pawn here
magnus defends it uh duda will bring the
the knight into the attack as well so we
might play rook to b1 but also knight
the c2 is gonna help so knight's the c2
the pawn is nicely defended now comes
knight to f6 the knight is being
remaneuvered to d5 to help out with the
attack against the b4 pawn
rook to b1 by magnus and now knight to
d5 so now duda is down upon but he has a
very
uh strong grip on the position and well
it's a question how magnus will proceed
here
we have rook to b3 now adding another
attacker to the a3 pawn here you might
even attack it further with bishop to c1
g4 by duda grabbing more space here
around the carson's king and now b5
magnus starts pushing his pass pawn we
have rook to b7 uh
and now bishop to c1 going after this
pawn here and now rook beat the a7 uh so
doubling up here adding another defender
to the a3 pawn and now everything is
defended well and it's a question how
magnus should continue it seems like you
could just start by pushing the b6 pawn
but it doesn't really offer that much
we're going to block it and now we're
attacking it twice so you can't just
advance pawns here but what you can do
is pause the video and try to figure out
the move that magnus played while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well just a very interesting idea yeah
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook to c5 this is
how magnus decided to go about this uh
this blocks bishop's defense of the a3
pawn and your next movie is just
capturing the pawn you're going to be up
two points and you're going to have a
winning end game uh what magnus wants is
that for do that to capture on c5 and
then magnus wants to play d captures on
c5 and have two connected pass pawns for
the price of the exchange uh but duda
first prepares it he plays rook the a4
it's a
it's a waiting move uh if magnus does a
sort of a slow move like king the g2
then he's going to capture captures
captures and then he's going to play
rook to c4 with an attack on the knight
and then the pawn
and then it's just going to be very good
for black so of course magnus doesn't
allow this he starts by capturing the a3
pawn
we have bishop captures on c5 now d
captures and now there's
no point in playing rook to c4 because
the knight just moves and the bishop
guards this pawn
and if you try to give back the exchange
captures captures and captures it's
still not all that great just rook here
we're gonna start pushing our pawns and
the white simply has too much here so
after d captures on c5 we have e5 by
duda
and now comes knight to b4 by magnus now
he wants to trade down as much as
possible and start pushing those pawns
uh duda should probably avoid trading
should probably move the night somewhere
like knights d7 but this is rapid chess
it's very hard to calculate what happens
after those pawns start marching forward
and you will you be in time to do
anything about it so here he trades with
bishop captures and rook captures an a2
and now magnus plays b6 uh and well b7
c6 c7 is coming
duda plays rook to c2 and now bishop to
c3 just blocking rook's attack towards
the
c pawn we have f6 by duda also defending
this pawn and now b7 andy was in this
position on move 36 that young sister
duda resigned the game and game one of
the match goes to magnus for this very
very interesting game uh you resigned
here because after the rook defense
there's really not much to do c6 c7 and
that's it that's that's game
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank david kimura vlad laro mark
thompson annie mccain and emman
lagevardi for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon uh
with the game alireza versus wesley as
that one is also uh just just a well
just a very nice game to see
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day